this is Timmy just arriving home from a  long hard day at school  hi Timmy Timmy's a bright kid with a  good head in the shoulders but there's  one thing Timmy doesn't know don't you  you know those blend average beans wheat  every day that just leave you feeling  empty Hollow and alone inside you're  gonna want to dust those beans but  grandma's knitting pile because there's  a new beam on the market that will  satisfy your taste buds like never  before  Clinton Brett's filibuster beans made  only with the freshest refried pork and  finest legumes there's meat in every  bite just cook and serve perfect with a  nice cold color to wash it all down  never again will you feel empty and  unsatisfied come on get a can or two of  Clinton vets filibuster beans at your  local grocery market today